[Music]
foreign
so here in this video we will showcase
the seven kaijus and monsters that are
related to Godzilla the ones whom their
existence will not be possible without
the essence of the G-Man with his DNA or
our close relatives to him these will be
from both Toho and American movies so
let's get to it the first one by olante
biolante is a unique and memorable
monster in the Godzilla franchise known
for its distinctive plant-based
appearance and complex origin story well
violente first appeared in the 1989 film
Godzilla vs biolante its Origins is
intricately tied to a character of Dr
genitiro shiragami in the film's
backstory shirigami a scientist had lost
his daughter whose name is Erica
shirigami to on his daughter's memory
his prices hurt cells with those of a
rose bush creating a hybrid entity when
Mount mihara Arabs the destruction
causes him a great deal of stress and
PTSD let's say he further splices the
DNA of Godzilla with a high hybrid Rose
intending to make it invincible and
capable of surviving any natural
disaster keeping the essence of its
daughter alive however this Fusion goes
Ori and the result is the creation of
biolante a monstrous plant like kaju
featuring massive Vines petals and
Central mouth in terms of genetic
relation biology is not a direct
offspring of Godzilla but rather a
fusion of Godzilla's DNA with the dad of
a hybrid Rose and Erica's cells
number two of course space Godzilla this
Kaiju space Godzilla is portrayed as a
mutated and space-born version of the
original Godzilla in the film Godzilla
vs Space Godzilla it arrives on Earth
with the intention of establishing
dominance over the planet its primary
target is Godzilla and the two engage in
a series of battles throughout the film
it was speculated that Godzilla's cells
were flung into space and fell into a
black hole these cells supposedly emerge
from a white hole and another end
rapidly evolving by assimilating
crystalline life forms and being exposed
to cosmic energy of exploding Stars the
exact cause of the cells entering the
black hole is uncertain in the movie but
there are two possibilities either cells
from bailante Escape Earth's orbit after
her battle with the GMAT in 1990 or
Mothra unintentionally carried the cells
into space on her wings in 1993 while
intercepting a meteor heading towards
Earth well the 2019 game Godzilla
Defense Force attributes Mothra as the
Kaiju responsible for space Godzilla's
Creation in his codex entry
number three Orga Orga is a Kaiju that
appeared in the 1999 film Godzilla 2000
Millennium Argos stories its Origins are
closely tied to an advanced alien race
known as the Millennials and they're
encountered with Godzilla so these
Millennials are an extraterrestrial race
that crash landed on Earth millions of
years ago they combined their Collective
biomass into a single dominant entity
awaiting the opportunity to become
active once more the millenniums
constantly seek for a suitable genetic
hose to further their conquest of Earth
and after scanning various life forms
including Godzilla they determined that
a G-Man is the ideal candidate the
millennial entity then attempts to
subdue Godzilla and absorb his DNA
however in the process something goes
wrong the Millennium is unable to handle
the volatile nature of Godzilla's
genetic material and it mutates
uncontrollably giving rise to a new
monstrous form known as orga the anime
series of films the Reva era suggests
another one that Orga could be a close
related species of Godzilla or a monster
derived directly from Godzilla's genetic
material
number four Zilla okay zilla's Origins
lie in the 1998 American Film Godzilla
this film reimagined the iconic Godzilla
concept presenting a more reptilian and
agile creature that was significantly
different in appearance and behavior
from the classic Touhou Godzilla in this
version Zilla is portrayed as a mutated
iguana that grows into colossal
proportions after exposure to nuclear
testing in the Pacific Ocean johor's
inclusion of Zilla in Godzilla final
wars and its subsequent treatment of the
character as a way of asserting the
supremacy of the original Godzilla
character and distancing themselves away
from the 1998 American interpretation in
the Godzilla anime Trilogy this Zilla
its specific Origins and genetic
relation to Godzilla are left vague and
open to interpretations various theories
arise and are presented suggesting that
Zilla could be a subspecies of Godzilla
or a creature directly derived from the
Godzilla genetic line but this could be
debated further in a future video
number 5 cyber Zilla in the Animated
Series cyber Godzilla is introduced as a
significant antagonist in the master
World storyline the character's Origins
are linked to the remains of the
original Godzilla of 1998 which had
perished in New York City in the events
of the movie after the death of the
original Godzilla it's carcass its dead
body was taken to a military base for
study the base is later infiltrated and
overtaken by an alien race known as the
Leviathan aliens these aliens possess
advanced technology and the ability to
manipulate and control monsters they
then use their technology to revive the
carcass of the original Godzilla
transforming it into a cybernetic
creature under their complete control
this new creation is referred to as
cyber Zilla or cyber Godzilla so the
same thing as the previous entry it's
either just a reimagined Gojira or if
it's by the anime logic a distinct
species closely related to Godzilla
number six Doug of protozilla or the
hollow Earth lizard so dark species is
characterized by its run physique short
legs and Jagged osteaderms covering its
back and shoulders its skin appears to
take an armor resembling that of a
crocodile suggesting that it had evolved
to withstand the challenging environment
within the hollow Earth in the monster
verse this creature's Jaws are filled
with large teeth indicating its
predatory nature duck is an example of
the film's effort to populate the hollow
Earth with an array of creatures
showcasing a rich ecosystem well the
origins of these Hollow Earth lizards
aptly named Doug remains largely
mysterious however it appears that they
underwent Evolution within the hollow
Earth itself attaining their significant
size the book Godzilla vs Kong one will
fall the art of the ultimate battle
royale yeah that's a long name it
implies that the hollow Earth lizards
might be a branch of the Titanic's
Gojira evolutionary lineage with their
Jagged dorsal plates and overall
appearance providing Clues to its
possible connection with the G-Man
number 7 Kiryu of course we have to
include a Mechagodzilla but this one is
pretty specific in Godzilla against
Mechagodzilla Kiryu is introduced as a
cybernetically enhanced Mecca built to
defend Japan from the threat of Kaiju
attacks and specifically from Godzilla
Kiryu is constructed from the skeletal
remains of the original Godzilla the one
that was defeated by the oxygen
Destroyer kiri's construction involves
integrating advanced technology with the
preserved bones of the original G-Man
creating a formidable weapon to combat
the Contemporary Godzilla that continues
to manage Japan kiri's design also
incorporates elements of both mechanical
and organic components including DNA
computers intended to mimic the behavior
of living organisms however the use of
this DNA sequence which might be linked
to Godzilla's DNA inadvertently leads to
curious susceptibility to Godzilla's
roar as the original Godzilla Spirit
remains attached to the bones this
aspect of curious design becomes a
crucial plot in the film causing Kyrie
to go berserk when exposed to Godzilla's
roar and that is his weakness and
connection to the G-Man
so those are the seven monsters related
to the Godzilla species at least you
know in a way either bones or genetic
material are maybe even a mutated form
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos here on this channel take care
fam